- Promets-moi que tu feras attention
-Je pars à la chasse.
Comment ça va ?
Tous ces bébés, ça doit te rendre dingue.
Je sais. Désolée. Je sais que tu voulais être enceinte.
Marcus Trenton et Vaughn Carter?
-Trois nuits ?
-Oui, c'est ça.
Vous avez choisi le week-end parfait pour être ici.
L'alcool coule à flots.
Profitez bien de la chasse.
Pas de doute.
Tu vas pouvoir avoir un cerf ?
Je ne pense pas, non.
C'est pas donné à tout le monde.
-On va voir la police et...
-Aller voir la police ?
Ce sera vu comme un meurtre
On rentre en ville et on revient ici ce soir.
On n'a pas le choix.
C'était une bonne journée de traque?
Le neveu de Logan a disparu.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez fait , hier soir?
Qu'est ce qu'on a comme preuve ?
Rien.
On a fait une erreur.
Je vais payer pour ça.
Ils sont partis!
Tout ce que j'ai fait ici...
ENTERRER LA VERITE
C'était pour nous protéger.
EN PAYER LE PRIX
Je suis désolé.
Ca n'est pas suffisant.
C'est loin d'être suffisant.